you did not enjoy the experience of
being batman
uh you've said that you said yeah it
just wasn't for me i probably never
should have done it
ben affleck called you i guess and said
hey they're offering me batman should i
take it you were so
down on that experience you told them
don't go near it right it's just a
disaster
he didn't listen to you of course and i
thought he did a nice job
but uh but people will call you for
advice right i mean they will say
they see you as the guy to call because
you're a director and an actor
i think also because i've been around
and also because i've done
you know i've i've sort of had both
rounds you know i've been
a big flop and i bombed in things and
i've had big successes and
it doesn't mean they listened ben didn't
listen to me and he ended up doing a
great job and i was wrong but
but i can only you know impart my wisdom
from my experience and
i i just said don't have nipples on the
suit you know
when a movie like that comes out and you
don't like it you know you just it's
just a bad experience for you
will you ever revisit that movie you
would never watch that movie again
no no it's it's so bad
that um it actually hurts to watch it's
physically like
you'll be flipping the channels and just
it'll just pop up and i'm like oh no no
no no
do you ever go you ever go oh i could
have done it differently i could have
done this this this and this do you ever
do you just let go of it i couldn't have
done that one differently you know
it's a big machine that thing right i
got you to remember at that point i was
just an actor getting an acting job i
wasn't the guy that could green light a
movie
right you know they you know they paid
arnold 25 million dollars to be in it
they paid me like
one and we never even worked together we
never saw each other
um it was you know it's it's a big
monster machine and i you know and i
just sort of jumped in and
did what they said and the truth of the
matter is
i was bad in it and you know it's a
terrible
i mean akiva goldsmith who's won the
oscar for
writing since then he wrote the
screenplay it's a terrible screenplay
he'll tell you you know i'm terrible in
it i'll tell you
joel schumacher who just passed away you
know directed it and he'd say yeah it
didn't work
you know we all sort of go yeah we all
we all whiffed on that one